est-ce que vous connaissez le point
commun entre le sang le sperme et la
moelle osseuse non ça n'a rien à voir
avec la lumière noire
[Musique]
rien à voir avec les sous-vêtements non
plus pour la moelle osseuse ce serait un
petit peu inquiétant pas de recette de
cuisine non plus non le point commun en
fait si on a deux on peut les donner
tous les trois et on en manque allez je
vous explique ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donner son sang vous connaissez donner
son sperme donner ses gamètes j'espère
que vous connaissez aussi parce que j'en
ai déjà parlé il y a quelques temps
maintenant c'était Noël je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez je vous avais aussi
parlé du don de moelle osseuse alors bah
évidemment je vais pas vous refaire la
même vidéo mais on va quand même en
reparler d'abord parce qu'il y a deux
trois petites choses qui ont changé
depuis et puis parce que je voudrais
insister sur un point précis pour que
vous compreniez pourquoi c'est important
que vous vous inscriviez sur les listes
de donneurs et pourquoi c'est important
qu'il y ait le maximum de monde avec le
maximum de profils différents d'ailleurs
avant de commencer un grand bravo à
toutes celles et à tous ceux qui m'ont
envoyé des messages après ma première
vidéo pour me dire qui s'était inscrit
c'est comme ça qu'on y arrivera alors
dans un premier temps je vous propose de
refaire rapidement un petit tour de la
question pour bien se remettre en tête
de quoi on parle exactement et pour
faire une ou deux petites mises à jour
on va faire ça point par point avec 6
trucs à savoir sur le don de moelle
osseuse à quoi ça sert de donner sa
moelle osseuse bah oui c'est vrai ça
donnez ok mais on aime bien savoir à
quoi ça va servir et bah donner ça moi
l'osseux ça permet de soigner des gens
et même de leur sauver la vie des gens
moelle osseuse fonctionne pas
correctement et pour qui la seule chance
de guérir c'est qu'on leur greffe une
moelle qui fonctionne bien et il y a
plusieurs maladies qui peuvent donner ce
genre de problème c'est des maladies
graves du sang et les plus connues c'est
les leucémies et ça concerne des
milliers de personnes de tous les âges y
compris des enfants mais c'est quoi la
moelle osseuse au fait attention déjà on
parle bien de la moelle osseuse pas de
la moelle épinière la moelle épinière
elle est blanche et grise elle est
cachée dans la colonne vertébrale dans
un canal au milieu des vertèbres et elle
fait partie de notre système nerveux
alors que la moelle osseuse celle qui
nous intéresse elle est rouge et elle
elle est à l'intérieur des eaux et donc
son boulot c'est de fabriquer les
cellules souches qui vont elles-mêmes
fabriquer les cellules qui composent
notre sang les globules rouges pour
transporter l'oxygène les globules
blancs pour lutter contre les infections
et les plaquettes qui ont un rôle dans
la coagulation comment ça se passe quand
on veut donner sa moelle alors c'est un
peu changé depuis la dernière fois mais
déjà c'est pas comme quand on donne son
sang là dans un premier temps il faut
juste s'inscrire sur une liste ça se
fait en ligne sur le site don de moi
osseuse.fr et je vous mets le lien dans
la description de la vidéo et ensuite
une fois qu'on a bien checké que vous
pouviez être donneuse ou d'honneur il
faut compléter le dossier et faire un
prélèvement qui va servir à établir
votre carte d'identité biologique je
vais vous expliquer après à quoi il va
servir là il y a deux options soit on
vous envoie la liste des documents à
fournir et un tube pour cracher dedans
enfin pour récupérer votre salive faut
pas vraiment cracher vous verrez ça dans
le jargon on appelle ça un prélèvement
salivaire c'est plus stylé soit vous
allez dans un centre vous remplissez les
documents avec un médecin et on vous
fait une prise de sang c'est vous qui
choisissez OK et après et après vous
attendez vous êtes inscrit sur ce qu'on
appelle le registre des donneurs
volontaires de moelle osseuse vous avez
votre carte de donneur et vous attendez
si un jour votre carte d'identité
biologique elle correspond à celle d'une
personne qui a besoin d'une greffe on
vous appelle vous faites des examens
complémentaires pour vérifier que vous
êtes bien compatible et en état de
données et si tout est ok on vous
convoque on vous prélève votre moelle
osseuse et on l'envoie à l'hôpital dans
lequel est soigner la personne qui va
recevoir la greffe entre le premier coup
de fil et le prélèvement il se passe
entre 1 et 3 mois donc tranquille et
peut-être que ça arrivera jamais il y a
beaucoup d'inscrits qui sont pas
contactés ok mais ça fait mal alors je
vous rappelle on parle pas de moelle
épinière on parle de moelle osseuse et
du coup pour récupérer de quoi faire la
greffe il y a deux options la plus rare
d'abord on prélève votre voile dans un
os dans la hanche souvent ça peut piquer
un peu au réveil mais c'est fait sous
anesthésie générale et vous restez 48
heures à l'hôpital où on s'occupe de
vous mais en fait dans 80% des cas c'est
une prise de sang un peu comme quand
vous donnez vos plaquettes je sais pas
si ça vous parle là ça dure 4 heures
votre sang il passe dans une machine qui
récupère les cellules souches et qui
vous rend le reste et puis après vous
mangez un truc et hop on en parle plus
et comment je sais si je peux donner
alors ça aussi ça fait partie des choses
qui ont un peu changé au moment où je
tourne les conditions pour s'inscrire
c'est avoir entre 18 et 35 ans ça c'est
pour s'inscrire mais une fois qu'on est
sur la liste on peut donner jusqu'à 60
ans être en bonne santé
c'est mieux pour tout le monde et
troisième chose avoir fait les démarches
dont je viens de parler voilà avouez que
c'est pas grand chose pour sauver une
vie mais attention c'est pas fini là on
a juste refait un petit peu le tour de
la question et si vous voulez plus de
détails je vous renvoie vers ma vidéo
précédente je vous remets le lien dans
la description mais comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure il y a un truc super
important sur lequel je veux m'attarder
c'est la fameuse compatibilité parce que
c'est important pour bien comprendre
pourquoi il faut qu'il y ait le maximum
de personnes inscrites sur les listes et
surtout des personnes au profil
génétique variés on l'a vu tout à
l'heure pour trouver un donneur ou une
donneuse compatible avec une personne
qui a besoin d'une greffe on fait un
prélèvement de salive ou de sang et on
établit une carte d'identité biologique
cette carte en réalité elle donne des
infos sur ce qu'on appelle le système
HLA c'est à dire le système des
antigènes des leucocytes humains les
leucocytes c'est le nom de nos globules
blancs qui font partie de notre système
immunitaire à la surface de nos cellules
il y a une substance les fameuses
antigènes qui font que nos cellules
elles sont ou pas par notre système
immunitaire si les cellules qu'on greffe
elles ont les mêmes antigènes que celles
du malade son système immunitaire est
dit ok c'est bon ils sont de la maison
on laisse passer mais si les antigènes
sont différents la le système
immunitaire isméphy et il les élimine
donc non seulement la greffe prend pas
mais en plus ça peut être dangereux donc
pour être sûr que tout se passe bien on
s'assure que le donneur et le receveur
ont bien les mêmes antigènes le problème
c'est que ce système HLA il est bien
bien plus complexe que le groupe sanguin
par exemple donc trouver quelqu'un qui
est pile compatible avec nous c'est
chaud mais c'est possible heureusement
tous les éléments du système HLA ils
sont transmis génétiquement ils sont
propres à chacun ils dépendent de
l'histoire des parents des
grands-parents des arrières
grands-parents etc donc le truc c'est
que plus on a de points communs
génétique avec le malade plus on a de
chances d'être compatible par exemple on
a 25% de chances de trouver quelqu'un de
compatible parmi ces sœurs ou ses frères
alors qu'entre deux personnes prises au
hasard c'est beaucoup moins et si on
trouve personne dans sa famille on a
plus de chances de trouver quelqu'un de
compatible parmi les gens qui ont les
mêmes origines ethniques que nous parce
que le système HLA il est aussi lié à
l'histoire des migrations de population
et aujourd'hui on constate que si une
patiente ou un patient a besoin d'une
greffe la probabilité de trouver un
donneur compatible dans le registre et
ben elle est plus grande si le patient
est d'origine coquinienne parce que
historiquement les registres ils se sont
plutôt développés dans l'hémisphère Nord
donc il y a une plus grande proportion
de population caucasiennes c'est un
constat c'est comme ça l'idée c'est
absolument pas de dire qui est inscrit
qui est pas ni de juger quoi que ce soit
l'idée c'est juste de rééquilibrer et de
dire que plus il y a de diversité parmi
les donneuses et les donneurs plus on a
de chances de trouver des personnes
compatibles avec le maximum de gens qui
ont besoin d'une greffe de moelle
osseuse pour guérir et si on en parle
pas bah au final les gens qui ont un
profil particulièrement recherché bah
ils sont pas au courant donc ils font
pas forcément les démarches de
s'inscrire sur le registre des donneurs
volontaires c'est logique et du coup il
y a des malades qui trouvent pas de
donneurs compatibles alors que ça
pourrait être si facile donc pour dire
des choses très clairement aujourd'hui
les profils ethniques les plus
recherchés c'est les donneuses et les
donneurs d'origine subsaharienne
maghrébine et asiatiques donc quel que
soit vos origines ethniques mais encore
plus si elles font partie de celles que
je viens de citer prenez le temps d'y
réfléchir bien sûr mais considérez
sérieusement la possibilité de vous
inscrire sur le registre maintenant vous
savez pourquoi c'est important pour
cette liste comme pour tout le reste le
métissage c'est une richesse voilà DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]